on behalf of dubai cares i would like to
congratulate mr ranjitsen desale
on winning the global teacher prize
2020. ranjit is a dynamic teacher whose
work has transformed the lives of his
students in india
and whose story has inspired many around
the world
today we honor his determination
kindness
and service to the next generation he
truly embodies the
very finest principles of the teaching
profession
in the dark days of covet 19 it is
teachers like ranjit
who are giving hope to children and
young people
today teachers around the world are
working day and night
to make sure that children keep learning
even when they cannot
enter the classroom at dubai cares
we've been working towards providing
children and youth in developing
countries with access to quality
education
since our inception in 2007 and since
then
we have successfully launched education
programs reaching
over 20 million beneficiaries in 60
developing countries
the entire team at dubai cares knows the
fundamental difference
that teachers make that's why supporting
teachers professional
development is a key thematic within our
program's portfolio
while the covet 19 pandemic has left a
significant impact on education
it will take all of us working together
to keep education alive throughout this
pandemic
that is why it is so important to
recognize and celebrate teachers like
ranjit
whose dedication and commitment will
change the world to a better place
thank you ranjit thank you for your
passion thank you for your efforts
i am confident that your fellow teachers
and yourself
will achieve your ambition to give
refugee children
their best hope of recovering from this
global crisis